whatever you want to do in your life you
got to kind of leave your comfort zone
the friends the family the cousins that
you hang out with all the time your best
friend and accumulating wealth is
momentum don't get in the way of
momentum you're gonna be 70 years old
overnight I promise you go by so quick
need motivation watch a top 10 on
believe nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from fleeing Iran at the
age of 10 during the Iranian Revolution
to joining the US hundred and first
Airborne Division to starting the PHP
agency' and the value tainment YouTube
channel meant to inspire millions of
people around the world he's Patrick
Bateman and here's my take on his top
ten rules of success volume 4
okay let's stick it up with rule number
one leave negative people behind
whatever you want to do in your life you
got to kind of leave your comfort zone
the friends the family the cousins that
you hang out with all the time that know
you for who you are you're saying this
is who I may be today but man I want
this life and for you to do this you
gotta leave them behind do you know how
many friends I had that when I was
deciding to go and spread my wings this
was the one line you ready here's a line
hey Pat so have you made your millions
yet path things is gonna be a
millionaire guys where's the millions
huh I used to see you drive a Ford
Expedition now you come with a Ford
Focus you are definitely becoming a
million it looks like you're going
backwards more than anything I remember
all these stories every one of them I
went from a big Ford Expedition I'd go
to all the parties everybody would go in
my car and we go together I lost
everything 49k in debt and boom I pull
up in a Ford Focus that I can barely fit
in everyone would say this is the guy
that's gonna be a millionaire you're the
guy that's gonna be somebody we should
fall on do business with give me a
flippin break and I was hated by my
friends for five years because that's a
leave them behind you want to come with
me let's go you don't want to come in no
problem I gotta go do what I got to do
you're never gonna pay my bills and I'm
not paying your bills I got to go do my
part not to go out there and do it it is
not an easy thing to do but if you're
watching this you're going through it if
you truly are serious with the effort
backed up to it go out and get exactly
what you want rule number two take
responsibility in life I've lost many
many times let me tell you many times
I've had girlfriends break up with me
I've had companies somebody didn't want
to do business with me I've had an
employee tell me they don't want to be
with me how that sales people that have
quit on me I've had so many people that
have had losses with I've competed
against people that are inferior than me
and I lost to them because that better
work ethic than me and I thought because
I had some talent that the time I was
gonna beat him no way in the world that
guy worked harder than me and I've also
competing against guys that were
superior than me and I worked my butt
off and I still lost I still lost with a
guy that was ahead of me what happened
there I worked my ass off and I still
lost yes that also happens it's called
the loss it hurts it's embarrassing you
come home your wife or your girlfriend
mom wants to make you feel good but you
know you're lost and it doesn't feel
good your peers are looking at you
competitors
looking at you the smirk that competitor
is gonna have when they give you a
high-five where they shake their hand to
kind of say good luck to you next time
you know that look still says that I
beat you that hurts
a girl breaks up with you that hurts but
here's the kicker here's the kicker
in that moment you will have a
temptation it's the biggest temptation
in life it's the most dangerous tant
temptation a lot it's the most powerful
temptation life let me tell what it is
in that moment you will have the choice
of either blaming something on the
outside or taking for responsibility
that temptation is so subtle no one
knows it no one knows it I have led
thousands of sales people that I've
worked with and I've seen some of them
keep growing growing growing growing
growing one guy went from 30 grand here
to 50 grand here 200 grand here to 200
300 400 500 600 700 million-dollar your
income while they had a lot of drama
fast in 3 years what happened to them
they never blamed they always took
responsibility
they never blamed and I've had people
that are 10 times more talented every
six months to have some kind of a subtle
stop you know why because they blame the
different circumstance well because of
this because it's this person's fault
that person's fault this person's fault
look in life it's gonna be very easy for
you to blame everybody very easy for it
done for you to blame everybody but one
day you'll sit down and people will say
how come you to make it bigger in life
you were very talented what happened
there you can make up any BS and sell
them because typically people who are
good at blaming other people are great
sales people you can blame everybody
else but there's one person that's gonna
know that you didn't take responsibility
and that's you that's a tough one to
live with rule number three be a
long-term thinker when number three is
long-term thinking the best example of
long-term thinking is one of the richest
men in the world and that's Warren
Buffett I want you to look at this chart
that I'm gonna put up and the part I
want to look at is how his wealth grew
from 18 years old to his 81 billion
dollars today that doesn't include the
billions of dollars that is given away
to charity so let's take a look at this
guy named Warren Buffett one of the
richest wisest smartest investors in the
world how did he amasses well so at the
age of 19 he had $10,000 to his name the
first million dollars he made he was 32
years old give or take fast forward to
the age of 40 years old
notice he had a thirty four million
dollar net worth right now watch what
happens here from thirty four million
dollars the next year or two it goes
from thirty four million dollars to
nineteen million dollars I think as much
as we spend time talking about how rich
this man is we forget to talk about this
moment in his career let me explain to
you why do you know how many people in
the world when they drop on thirty four
million to nineteen million dollars
that's 50% of the waters gone what do
you think most people do they cash out
they take their money out they listen to
news the news the same world you know
it's the world's coming to an end war is
coming through you know this is what's
gonna happen that's what's gonna happen
price of oil oh my gosh panic panic
panic panic panic everyone reacts this
guy says I trust my discipline because
I'm a long-term thinker and watch what
happens here
he goes from nineteen million dollars to
sixty-seven million dollars two billion
dollars at fifty-six to eighty 1 billion
dollars today let me compare is a net
worth to some of the countries in the
world watch this year Guatemala
he's got more than Guatemala Costa Rica
Luxembourg Slovenia Serbia Tunisia Ghana
ruge Y Kenya Ethiopia Lebanon Bulgaria
boos Pakistan Croatia Lithuania Warren
Buffett is beating those countries one
human being is beating countries rule
number four
choose success one of the scariest
moments of my life was the day I
realized amantani it's very scary that
day I realize I can have exactly the
life that I want to have this doesn't
mean you can go become whoever you want
to be not at all I don't think I can go
be LeBron James I don't jump 44 inches
and I'm not six eight to eighty I can't
sell you can go become anybody one you
can go be Michael Phelps no you can't
these are very obvious things to know
not everybody can be Michael Phelps
right I can't go today decided become
Michael Phelps I can't go today decide
to become the next Ted Williams
I can't certain things you cannot do and
that's okay not everybody can go out
there and do a lot of things other
people are doing however however
logically and emotionally let me explain
it to your last night we're having
dinner
okay and if you are cross station is the
arm family this place in Beverly Hills
it's just an incredible restaurant and
I'm speaking of my sister and I said
let me ask you a question she said yeah
everybody's like what yes I said out of
what we ate tonight what did we know
that we shouldn't have eaten if we
didn't want to put on more weight or
carry on more additional carbs starch
whatever maybe right and everybody said
well noodles said what else well the the
the the dessert we just said okay what
else and so we went through it right
though you know the the crabs that we
had that the lobster W had Lila oil in
it okay great
why do we eat it because we chose to eat
it why do we eat it cuz it's good okay
but we ate it yeah but we know it's not
good right yes but we ate it yes so
that's a scary thing let me explain to
you why we know if we ate it we have to
2x the cardio the next day and if we
don't eat it we don't have to to X the
cardio the next day because if we to X
the cardia the next day we're getting
closer to getting shredded right or
looking better or cutting some bringing
out more the muscle be more defined be
more vascular but we ate we chose to eat
it
okay the same goes that no one needs to
teach you and I that if you drink a lot
the night before an important sale in
the morning so you go out there
Wednesday night after everything is done
you go ham get hammered you party till 1
o'clock in the morning you know you got
an 8 o'clock appointment a morning too
close if I don't drink and I prepare 10
times more than you do and you drink you
get hammered you party you stay up and
you come the next day lethargic I'm
gonna close the deal over you are over
you you know that I know that so what
happens there here's a scary part every
one of the decisions you make you know
stain on newsfeed Facebook isn't good
for you because you can read a book
instead of that you know it you know
yourself going partying three four times
a week is not good you know nobody needs
to tell you that you know it you know
exercising is good for you you know it
no one needs to make five more million
videos to tell you that you need to go
out there and you know
what to do you know it so logically you
know what to do you know what not to eat
you know exercise is good for you you
know communication works you know
reading books works you know all this
stuff why you choose not to do it as the
other part so let me give you the
emotional side of it the emotional side
of it is we're such great sales people
because we convinced ourselves we have a
lot of time left we convinced ourselves
that I can do it tomorrow man I'm only
22 I can do it tomorrow only 39 I mean
she's got half my life to live young I
mean my twenties I should party I'm only
nine Tests you go out there and just
hang out who cares about being the
discipline I can learn discipline of my
40s right I don't need to take your my
body I'm 25 I'm hot I'm a girl I'm
drop-dead gorgeous I don't need to work
out I'm hot I thirty-five when it goes
it goes so you emotionally sell yourself
on not having to do the work so now you
watching this there's two different
kinds of people one person's like I was
hoping to get motivated oh my gosh I
wanna I want you to motivate no no the
second person is watching this says this
I control the kind of a life I can build
and live why am I not making the right
choices to be able to build a life for
myself
I don't know only you can answer that
not me not anybody else only you I had
to choose others had to choose what are
you going to choose now here's another
part of the scary part you're gonna be
70 years old overnight I promise you I
go by so quick are we gonna be 55 years
old overnight I look around you look at
your parents did you think your parents
were gonna be that age did you didn't
you think your parents were gonna be
around for a long time some of you guys
don't have your mom and dad here with
you I'm here in LA right now for one
reason my dad's brother passed away I'm
at a funeral that's 66 years old he
passed away no one expected this man to
pass away in Iran he passed away that's
why I'm in LA life goes by quickly
the sooner you and I choose to make the
decisions that we know are right for you
and I that you have control over the
sooner we start getting the kind of
results that get us to the dream life
that we want to live the only challenge
is you have to make the right choices
and no one else can do that for you
rule number five face the monster under
your bed face the monster on your bed
let me tell what I mean by facing the
monster under your bed as kids some kids
go to sleep and they feel like there's a
monster under their bed like think about
it I was a kid I was afraid to put on my
arm out you know why because I thought
there was a monster under the bed I
don't know if you had this I was afraid
of how my legs out the blanket had to
cover me I'm telling you as a kid now
this somebody may say you're out of your
mind some of you may say that's that was
me
I was afraid what if my leg is at a
master pose my lickers you would see
this you know my sister would
intentionally put nightmares on
Nightmare on Elm Street and I call my
gosh Freddy Krueger could be coming out
and go to sleep dreaming about Freddy's
under your bed Freddy what was that one
song with Freddy Freddy look at then and
how did it go
1 2 he's looking for you I'm sure
they're putting the song up for you to
hear that song screwed with my head in
Iran I was more scared of Freddy Krueger
than Saddam Hussein Iran and Saddam used
to bomb us all the time it doesn't
matter you gotta face it as simple as go
under your bed and realize there's
nobody there look in the in the shown
narcos the character Steve Murphy whom I
just said with a couple weeks ago
anyways interview is gonna come out here
pretty soon he says the following thing
and I think it's like season 2 episode
number 11 or something like that when
when they kill Pablo he says all that
time hunting him and just like that I'm
looking down at Pablo effing Escobar for
years I've been building up this son of
a [ __ ] in my head what a monster he
b-but here's the thing when you lay eyes
on him the devil's a real letdown just a
man
beer groan doesn't shave fat and
shoeless you know what his point is
Pablo was this big it was a devil he was
evil can be taken down everyone was
afraid of him and then he's dead when
you face your fears and you look at him
you're so disappointed because it's not
a big deal it's very simple once you
face it for so many people they never
have that moment that Steve Murphy had
an in the show narcos or in real life
against Pablo Escobar they don't have it
so some people are 85 and that fear is a
reality because they never faced it rule
number six minimize regrets regret
minimization I've spoken about in a
couple other videos minimize the number
of regrets when you look back you don't
to be able to say I messed up here with
drugs I did this year I did the divorce
I did that oh my gosh I got it
so many dumb mistakes I made that you
could have prevented yourself on making
it for some of you that are saying I
feel bad because I just went through
divorce three years later you make me
feel bad our current president is on a
third marriage you're okay just to
minimize the amount of regrets that
you're gonna have because it doesn't
stunt the momentum that you have your
best friend and accumulating wealth as
momentum don't get in the way of
momentum water it so gets bigger and
bigger and bigger rule number seven
address conflicts I am today not a big
fan of dead weight for a longest time I
somehow someway always had some dead
weight but the dead weight is when you
and your mind know you have a conflict
with an individual but you don't want to
address it the longer you delay that the
issue gets bigger and bigger both for
you and the other person now this is
assuming this is a person you want to
have a relationship with so now that
could be an ego saying it which you
don't you do you're just trying to be
cocky about it I'm not talking about
that I'm talking sincerely I honestly
don't want to have a relationship with
this person I'm okay about it great
that's not the person I'm talking about
I'm talking about the person you do want
to have a relationship with that is
critical for the success of your
business and it is critical for the
success of your happiness and your life
this could be family you gotta get on
the phone with them ASAP I made four
calls
today I made for yesterday I had a sit
down each of them range around an hour
and a half to three hours to an hour and
a half each call there was a conflict
there they were all different types of
conflicts there isn't a single one that
was similar to the other one not a
single one of them but they all were
conflicts we got on the phone
tension in the first 17 seconds 30
seconds call continues then it's solid
then it's open you're open I want to
talk about it are you open - yeah let's
talk about it listen this matters to me
if it matters to you let's address it
great there was things that I'll sit in
as citizen I'm not comfortable with this
decision that we made okay great yeah
I'm not comfortable with the decision we
made here this is my thoughts you want
me to tell you my thoughts or you just
want me kind of keep it to myself no
share with me your thoughts here's my I
think about this well here's what I
think about this great there is a
resolution if you're willing right in my
career eventually I got to a point I
said listen I don't have any time for
this I'm getting on the phone making
these calls if they matter 95% of the
calls I made and I got on the phone with
the individual and we addressed the dead
weight 95% of the time we solved it a
hundred percent of the time when I
didn't call it it was always wrong and
got worse and worse and worse
rule number eight have integrity I know
a lot of times people say well that
person is a little bit you know it's
interesting how he is I don't know he
kind of will go to the gray area or
he'll go to this area he'll go to that
area fine other people want to say that
no problem people who stay with a
founder for long enough all the time
they know that person may be crazy but
there are certain things they're not
gonna cross if you cross the line there
how would you keep the best talent how
would you keep the best smart people
around you you're just not gonna do it
if you struggle with integrity you're
gonna lose a lot of people that is a
quality so necessary I think Warren
Buffett said there's three things he
likes right energy integrity and
competence yeah I think those were the
three things he says without integrity
forget the other two right I want to say
those are the three things that he had
the point is to build a big business you
need people around you to trust you just
as much as you trust them that requires
integrity rule number nine network
network in look I can take my business
back to 1999 when I went to a man's
house who was a millionaire and he had a
big party and I made a lot of
relationships after the relationship two
years
introduced me to a guy that introduced
me to a guy in 2003 that contact is what
led me to making 30 million dollars just
off of one sale you know I went to an
insurance conference a few years ago met
a guy we didn't hit it off we had a
terrible call together one time I'm
talking a 5-minute call that was
horrible horrible call I said we'll
never do business with this guy he came
back said I still want your business
what can we do to make this work we made
it work fast forward he's the one that
ended up putting me in contact with De
La Hoya and couple other guys that
raised ten million dollars for business
these were contacts we networked we went
through it look at Zuckerberg he goes to
Harvard meets a kid named Edward meets
the Winklevoss brothers that leads to
Facebook you look at Warren Buffett who
networks and meets a guy named Charlie
Munger who he thinks is smarter than he
is and that bring those two together
build the empire that they built
everything's about networking in your
context especially if you want to
increase your wealth let me put it to
you this way it is very difficult for a
billionaire to befriend somebody that's
for $20,000 very difficult you know why
because the experiences are different
and level of thinking is different if
you hang with a billionaire your $20,000
somehow some way is gonna get higher
somehow some way this thing gets hard
because you're borrowing their thinking
you're borrowing who they know you're
borrowing their associations and rule
number 10 the last one we for a very
special bonus clip is tell great stories
so one day I'm sitting in the sales
appointment and this guy walks and he
looks very sharp and I'm looking at the
sky I said man he looks sharper why does
he smell so bad like he smells terrible
did he just go to the bathroom like man
wipe yourself clean yourself what is
wrong with you he smell terrible
and he's sitting in front of me and
typically an appointment sales
appointment would take me an hour hour
and a half and said listen I can't sit
next to somebody that smells this bad so
I cut this appointment fast I was very
frustrated said how does somebody have
the audacity to not even take care of
themselves when they come in I mean his
shoes did you step on poop what is wrong
with you so I cut the appointment very
quickly I said buddy I got another call
I gotta make we're good to go so he
leaves I go and I listen to this guy man
I haven't seen a guy that smelled this
bad I've never done on a poem with a guy
that smell this bad so I go to the
bathroom and when I go to the bathroom
and I look at myself in the mirror I had
my kids earlier and when I had my kids
earlier on my tie his poop all the way
on my tie okay and the person who
smelled like she was this guy here not
the guy I'm selling it to it was
embarrassing because the entire time the
man was so kind
nice to me and you can see the stains on
my tie here he never brought it up if
you're watching this my apologies to you
I promise you moving forward I will
never have poop on my tie ever again but
if you've ever done a sales appointment
and you're worried about how I wanted
these things in your teeth you know and
you look at something identica take that
thing out nothing is gonna be worse than
having poop on your tie now I've got a
really special bonus gift from Patrick
on how to position yourself properly
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action so here we go
question number one what negative people
in your life do you need to leave behind
question number two what's the monster
under your bed that you need to face and
question number three what decision do
you need to act on today so you do not
live with regrets
once you get out of college once you get
out of high school you have a choice on
what you wanted you can go get a regular
job you change your you trade your work
for hours I make fifteen bucks an hour
20 bucks an hour 30 dollars an hour and
that's fine and a lot of America is just
chasing that there will pay me $16.24
they're chasing this right and what they
don't realize is that's not how you
create wealth there's got to be an
element of you saying I know for a fact
if I position myself here and if I can
become an entrepreneur or if I can get
equity or if I can get ownership and how
do I get that part this can lead them to
something bigger for myself that's why I
say positioning if you keep trading
hours for a dollar that you're getting
paid you're gonna be limited there's got
to be a part where you go out and
position yourself properly I've said
this story many times
I live in wealthy communities and in
these wealthy communities everybody I
talked to I asked him how did you make
your money you know I made my money
because I started a business great I
made my money because I was part of a
startup and guess what happened to this
startup I was there for five years I
ended up getting piece the company five
years later the company was bought by
this company four billion dollars I got
my six million dollars I got my eight
hundred thousand dollars I got my 2.2
million dollars it's positioning so
wherever you're working at ask yourself
the positioning of the environment
you're in is it consi going up with
there's a possibility for bigger upside
or is it linear hurry up and change it
and if you choose not to change it then
don't be surprised if you don't have 750
thirty thousand dollars because you
chose the position you're currently in
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that passion
[Music]
now one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me
if you love Patrick I think you're also
going to love tom bill you from impact
theory we just did a top 50 rules of
success on him go check it out I think
you'll enjoy continue to believe and
I'll see you there the only credit I
will give myself is when other people
break and give up and stop I just don't